[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
august is here once again and the
biggest games are beginning to pop up
to buy for your attention this is the
series in which we shine a light on the
full price
reduced price and totally to play games
you may want to pick up
this month show us what you've got
august 2021
kina bridge of spirits arrives on august
24th an action adventure outing that is
like a blend of
zelda breath of the wild and pikmin kina
is a spirit guide who spends the game
helping the dead move into the spirit
world
if she doesn't then the deceased becomes
stuck between worlds which is bad news
for the one she's in
of course it doesn't always go to plan
and kina must use her staff
and abilities to fight off enemies and
take a look at these things
the rot cute beings who can be found in
the world to help keena complete tasks
and they even get involved in fights too
bridge of spirits includes many upgrades
and alternative abilities
such as turning her staff into a bow and
story wise some of it will be told in
flashbacks with kina's father
explaining how she got that scar on her
arm kina bridge of spirits releases on
ps4 and ps5
and pc on august 24th and is 40
in the us that's 33 quid here in the uk
pretty cheap for a game in 2021
next we have ghost of tsushima directors
cut
this is the release of the original game
plus all the multiplayer shenanigans
added over the last year
and best of all a brand new island for
jin sakai to explore
iki island introduces a new story new
mini games hidden around the world
and of course new enemies to outsmart if
you are new to ghost imagine assassin's
creed
set in feudal japan and you've pretty
much got this spot on
a fully open and explorable world with
countless collectibles and side quests
dotted around so many that you'll forget
the core story completely
the swordplay is designed to reward
great timing with brutal strikes
straight out of a samurai movie if you
played before then
ultimately this is more ghost of
tsushima which sounds good to me
a thing i really should note is that the
game has the most confusing upgrade
system i've ever seen
so let's simplify it if you own the
original game know that the director's
cut
is available as like a dlc and therefore
it's a reduced price
august 20th if you're interested only
for playstation
at least for now
[Music]
okay let's move on to the free games for
the month and a game i think you should
consider trying whether you're on
playstation xbox or pc
this is split gate an arena shooter
which describes itself as halo meet
portal hefty claims split gates gun
mechanics and movement
are clearly based around halo with a
similar sci-fi theme
and weaponry but now add to this a
portable wormhole
each player has at their disposal
shooting two rifts at different
locations
links both together and allows us to
walk run jump
and even shoot through this one mechanic
makes split gate completely unique
let's not get too excited for a moment
though we only have a selected number of
walls we can use to portal to so nobody
can
camp impossible to reach areas and
instead portals force us to play a
certain way
knowing that at any time someone could
blindside you is a real possibility
and that makes splitgate a thrill ride
it is possible to set up a trap though
oh it's possible
splitgate has been in open beta over the
last two weeks and the full release
completely free to play by the way is on
july 27th
that's tomorrow if you're watching when
i release this video or if it's after
that
it's already out go play it on pc
playstation and xbox
okay another free game but a quick note
that this is only free on ps plus from
august the 3rd
this is hunters arena legends i showed
you this a few weeks ago and the moment
everyone noticed this was a battle
royale title they ran a mile
i get it i really do genre fatigue is
real so this time i won't tell you about
the 30 person br mode or the 30 player
trio br mode
instead know that there is a tag match
mode
which they say is tekken style
one-on-one fighting
in an enclosed area you'll choose your
favorite legend and beat the hell out of
the other player
perfecting combos and timing defenses is
everything this game mode is about
and remember if you don't like this
there's a battle royale game mode too
you know if you fancy it hunter's arena
legends releases on console on
playstation 4 and 5 on august the 3rd
and during the first month you can grab
it for free if you're a ps plus
subscriber
[Music]
okay so the first full price game of the
month unless you're on xbox game pass
can i say game pass without being
harassed psychonauts 2
about 16 years ago the first psychonauts
game released
and this one begins only a few hours
after that one
ended you may be thinking that the art
style looks like hot trash
yeah i certainly understand where you're
coming from it's not for everyone but if
you can get past the tim burton meets
childlike simplicity visuals
there is so much more this game has to
offer a third person platformer with a
focus on a vastly improved fighting
system
dodging in and out of battle is key to
progressing and the telekinesis on offer
here is akin to the game control
and it never gets old away from fighting
it's the story which could be the hidden
gem
enemies are physical representations of
emotions
like self-doubt and regret and without
realizing it you may learn a thing or
two about mental health
if you're interested look out for
psychonauts 2 on ps4 xbox and pc
take a look-see at this alien's fireteam
an official aliens tie-in if you'd like
to be scared witless
set 23 years after the movie fire team
puts us in a squad of three real players
and sends us to a distress beacon in
which the aliens
have taken over thousands and thousands
of them
previewers have commented on the detail
of the interiors and weaponry on offer
and how it keeps with the lore of the
franchise for all it tries to be friar
team is essentially a shooter there are
cover mechanics they
they don't really need to be there to be
completely honest and there are classes
and abilities too
but mainly you'll be pointing a gun and
shooting a butt ton of xenomorphs
alien fire team drops on august 24th on
playstation pc
and xbox
[Music]
oh a quick shout out to the brilliant
hades
this beast of a game was on many
people's game of the year list
last year well finally playstation xbox
gamers can understand what the switch
and pc peeps have been shouting about
for so long
hades is simply brilliant it's a
roguelike dungeon crawler
roguelikes are here to punish you each
time you die you start the game again
completely from the beginning the
brilliance of roguelikes is that certain
weapons and abilities can be unlocked
permanently
meaning they'll be there the next time
you start your next run making that run
slightly easier hopefully hades combines
greek mythology with hack and slash
mechanics
and it's a game which is almost
impossible to sell in one minute so
instead i will say if you like
roguelikes
or you fancy a challenge play this it's
brilliant
hades hits ps4 and ps5 and xbox one and
the xbox series
on august 13th oh before our last game a
quick reminder that marvel's avengers
has a free trial from july 29th
to august the first on playstation steam
and stadia
there's been a bunch of new free content
added so maybe it's time to give it a
chance or jump back in again oh and also
last month we talked about the game
little demon inside and it was planned
to release in july
well there hasn't been any information
at all for over a month now
and it could drop at any moment so i'll
keep an eye on that if you were waiting
for it last month i'm
sorry it just hasn't materialized yet
so our final game and it's not on
playstation i'm very sorry it will make
it over to us but right now i think the
idea is so good it needs shouting about
this is 12 minutes it's a loop-based
game which lasts a total of you've
guessed it 12 minutes each time you play
in a point-and-click adventure here's
the premise you return home to your wife
who is carrying your baby when all of a
sudden a policeman bursts in and arrests
her
killing her in the process gut-wrenching
right it's then your job to relive that
day multiple times to prevent this from
happening and to find out what is going
on
i think this is a great idea and i
honestly can't wait to try it
august 19th if you have an xbox or a pc
august 19th
i'm sure we'll get it one day
playstation fan and in the meantime i'll
be playing this on release day on my
second channel
if you like the concept so there we have
it eight new games for the month of
august 2021 if you're still here write
down
a name of a random animal and your
favorite pop song and i'll give you a
dungeons and dragon name that's random
because why not
i'm adam you're awesome i'll see you
next time
[Music]